well
[Music]
hello, how are you, andrés gonzález,
with your brief information for today, Tuesday
, October 19, a person died this
morning after an accident where the
driver fled west of the
valley, this happened on sahara avenue
at 3  jones and terpins around 1:30
a.m. authorities
said the victim was crossing in his
assigned crosswalk when he was
struck police are still on the
driver's tracks
an investigation is ongoing
after a man
died in police custody this
happened yesterday afternoon near fort
apache and 11 officers responded to the
scene to assist paramedics
with a medical episode that's when they
found a man acting
erratically in a bathroom
authorities managed to handcuff him but  at
that time the man was seen
unconscious he was later pronounced
dead at the
hospital clear county already has the
funds  enough to rename
mccarran airport
commissioner text agger bloom said
these donations reached an
estimated $4.2 million this
change to
harbor brigde international airport has been covered
entirely by private donations for
more details on the different
phases of the process of change you can
visit our page news now dotcom
diagonal in Spanish
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have some breezes for today
reaching a maximum of 73 degrees in
the afternoon this weekend temperatures will rise
to 80 but
we will continue with a  nice weather
for next week I am andrés gonzález
and this can about the news
broadcast in Spanish happy day
[Music]